foreign
[Music]
today I'm going to be talking about
value realization in laboratory
automation
how we can identify and Achieve
attainable goals
I work for a company called
syntago it's located in the San
Francisco Bay area in California in the
United States
if you browse to our website you will
see our mission statement which is uh
displayed here on the slide syntago is a
genome engineering company that enables
the acceleration of life science
research and development in the pursuit
of improving human health
at syntago we believe that we can
industrialize life science
people can serve to our site and Order
crispr Gene editing kits as well as
engineered cells
we believe that life science will be
Advanced by a combination of biology and
Engineering disciplines
we focus on crispr Gene editing which is
a relatively simple cheap and precise
technique for genome editing the figure
on the right shows the principle behind
crispr
a guide RNA guides a cas9 protein to a
Target area on the genome the cas9
protein causes a double-stranded break
indicated by dsb in the figure this dsv
can cause a gene Knockouts meaning that
the gene is no longer functional
or alternatively in combination with
some donor DNA a gene knock in happens
for example to repair the functionality
of a gene
at syntago we fabricate both guide rnas
for our customers who want to do the
editing themselves but we also provide a
service of engineered cells on demand
so our Core Business is to provide cell
editing as a service so that our
customers can focus on the consequences
of the edits for example to study
disease models drug response or to
develop cures for genetic diseases and
cancer
this is very similar to ordering uh
electronic circuit boards from a from a
vendor
you don't really care about how the
circuit board is being made or how the
chips work
you really care about the functionality
of the boards
this we want to enable this Paradigm in
biology
so my name is Arno Vandenberg I'm the
director of Automation and systems
engineering at syntago and on the right
here you see a picture of my team
members
these people have backgrounds in physics
biology chemical engineering electrical
engineering Robotics and mechanical
engineering
industrializing biology is not
necessarily simple or easy and we
believe that we need multi-disciplinary
approaches
to tackle these problems
the team's mission is to establish and
support process automation across
syntago both using commercially
available equipments as well as building
and validating in-house Hardware
let's talk a little bit about laboratory
automation
when engaging on lab automation we often
want the moon on a stick we want fully
automated processes that can run with as
little as possible supervision and that
can run day in Day Out
however achieving that final goal can be
challenging it can be a long and windy
road towards that end goal and if you
don't anticipate that the the road is
lengthy the process can be a bit
frustrating
so if you only focus on the end goal
we will have challenges
I would like to point out today that we
can create value along the journey
when talking about value creation this
cartoon here really says a lot more than
a thousand words
if we want to build a car
but we start with a wheel and then a
chassis and then perhaps a body and then
ultimately a car we will only create
value at the end
the journey is long and windy and quite
frankly the probability to come up with
a car is rather low you might come up
with something else than a car if on the
other hand as indicated by the bottom
half of the figure we start by building
something that already brings us faster
from A to B like a skateboard for
example we do create some value maybe
not much but it's something something
that we can immediately use if next we
build a bicycle and then perhaps we add
an engine to keep adding value
um we keep creating value as we develop
the final product
this is also indicated by the happiness
of the smiley face in the figure
ultimately we may never end up with a
sedan or like the car we initially
designed but we have created value
nonetheless along the way while every
time becoming more efficient in what we
want to achieve in this case moving from
place a to place B so even when we don't
completely achieve the end goal our
customers and whether that's lab
operators as senior managers can be
happy
so intermediate goals may look like they
are far off from the end goal but that
doesn't matter
each of the intermediate goals add value
and it's important to identify the value
created within the iterative steps to
keep going and to achieve ultimately the
final goal of full automation
so I'm going to highlight five different
topics and the first topic is the Autumn
that automation brings process
standardization
whenever we are going to automate
processes on lab equipment we will force
ourselves to Define our processes to an
intricate detail
when that process or even part of that
process is automated we will reduce
operator dependency and we will enforce
the same starting conditions
and this is how we can achieve
standardization and have a much larger
chance of having repeat repeatable
and predictable processes
and as an example I would like to
highlight our capability of producing
engineered cell libraries
so this is one of the products we offer
at syntago
at ecl engineered cell library is a
library where we knock out every Gene
that is important for a process one at a
time and the intended result is a
microtider plate of cells with a
different Gene knocked out in each well
for example we can knock out the immune
system genes to study the efficacy of
certain drug therapies
one of our customers requested to knock
out 300 genes with two replicates so
that is 2 600 edits in total we then
also needed to stimulate a response in
each of the wells and collect the cell
supernatant
obviously for these amounts of edits
we'd like to use Automation and we did
and although it wasn't the moon on a
stick I believe we did achieve
significant value by standardizing the
process
let me first give some background in how
crispr editing actually works the first
thing that we need to do for crispr
editing is to make the guide RNA cas9
complex this is also known as a
ribonuclear protein rmp
then secondly we need to deliver the rmp
inside the cell nucleus and for that we
use a process called electroporation
where we apply an external electric
field across the cells
that external electric field forces the
cell membrane to open so that the rmp
complex can enter the cell once the E
field is gone return once we turn it off
the cell membrane goes back to its
natural state but the rmp the guide RNA
and cas9 will be inside the cell and so
editing can happen
now in the lab what we need is we we use
micrositer plates we add cas9 protein
and guide RNA inside the plates together
with a transfection buffer
we also add cells into that plate now
this could be a regular plate but to do
transfection we need a dedicated
transfection plates indicated on the
right here in the figure this is a plate
where each of the wells is covered with
electrodes so that we can apply a field
across each well
as mentioned before we use the
automation to other quote these reagents
for the low volume transfers we use the
Beckman Echo
and to dispense the transfection buffer
we used a manual pipette as I said not
everything was automated for this
process
and the cells are adequate it's using a
gigger circus
and a 384 plate stem from the regular
384 plate into the transfection plate
was done using Hamilton's star
next we bring the transfection plate to
an electric operation device that device
actually zaps 384 Wells sequentially
while transfection is ongoing a recovery
plate is filled with recovery media
using a biotech el-406 and after
transfection cells are transferred to
the recovery plate using a Hamilton star
we have we put these devices in uh in an
automated work cell within an ISO 5
enclosure the iso 5 reduces the
probability of contamination that could
be bacterial or fungal contamination
so for this process we use the Hamilton
liquid Handler the lonza 384 well
nuclear Factor back when Echo biotech
dispenser and the combi dispenser
I'm going to show a little video of how
the plate is being brought to the
nuclear Factor while
the recovery plates are being prepared
the nuclear factor is in the lower right
corner of the video that plate is being
presented now we discarded the lid and
we bring it to the biotech device
to this to uh dispense recovery media
then that plate is brought to the
Hamilton deck
of course you didn't see the Hamilton
deck that's in the next
here we see how the transfection plate
is being brought to the Hamilton deck
and then Hamilton robot will move that
plate internally so uh the transfer can
happen
this was our first massive screen so
remember 2600 edits
and the process needed a lot of
hand-holding or also scaffolding as you
can see an example of Scaffolding in a
picture on the right
it was actually supervised by the entire
team
not everything was automated not all
dispensers were integrated with the work
cell we had the manual edition of the
transfection buffer and we had to
prepare the Hamilton deck manually
but nonetheless
by using the automation equipment or
even partial partial automation
equipment it required us to immediately
Define the process and so we achieved
standardization and so if our next
customer to come along with a similar
large engineered cell screen
we would be ready and we can we could
actually iterate on top of this design
next I would like to see like to
highlight how automation can avoid
bottlenecks in the process
um talking again about this engineered
cell library assay
once we have the edited cells in 384
well plates the task at hand is to
expand these into 96 valve plates
the customer actually wanted to do that
twice to create two technical replicates
what the customer then also wanted is to
induce a response in the ecl the
engineered cell library
and after we induce the response measure
the plates in the plate and in a plate
imager within 24 hours
so we we had eight 384 cell plates a
well played sorry of edited cells that
went into
64.96 well plates
now if in all these plates we need to
induce a response and image it 24 hours
later
when Imaging takes about 10 to 15
minutes you could see that you can
create a bottleneck
to make a case here I'm going to use
some slides that were generated by
high-res bio
what we see here on top is a gunshot of
actions going on with four assay plates
in a system where we have a liquid
handling Deck with four shakers and four
thermal circles so before any action
happens we need to wait until all assay
plates are loaded so there is an amount
of waiting time
at the beginning of the thermal cycling
and there's a waiting time at the end
this is called batch processing if on
the other hand we go to streaming
where a robot arm would feed blades to a
thermal cycler that is no longer on deck
of the liquid Handler but somewhere in
the work cell we see that the processing
time for each of the plates is now
uniform
does this streaming approach accounts
for process unification and avoids
bottlenecks
all plates are treated identically
and to make a case even further we can
go to an extreme example if we go up to
100 blades we can see that streaming
significantly significantly reduces the
time
but more importantly it allows for
process unification
there is no variable waiting time
between assay plates
we applied a streaming process to the
ecl screen where we had different
processes the first process was the
transfection and process 2A was the
expansion from 384 into 96 and the
second process was the Imaging of those
96 valve weights
um so here you see the process on on in
red or orange yellow and the two greens
for five transfections
and we could arrange it so that we'd
never had overlap between the pro the
Imaging processes to be
the third point I'd like to highlight
how automation also allows for process
miniaturization
and bringing it back to crispr we can
talk a little bit about crispr quality
control
now quality control is typically done
with DNA sequencing where we read back
the genome that we edited
Next Generation sequencing provides the
best sequencing quality and is cheapest
when doing many edits
NGS also has the advantage of being
massively parallel we combine many
different targets into one sequencing
Rune and in our case we combine 1536
samples into one vial of course we need
to label these samples but that's part
of the NGS Library preparation workflow
once we have this one vial with the 1536
samples that file can go into the
sequencing instrument
in our NGS reactions we start with cell
lysis that gives us genomic DNA
we then perform two PCR reactions one to
amplify the gene of interest and want to
add barcodes to the region of Interest
after these two PCR reactions we do a
size selection procedure using magnetic
beads
now importantly each of the PCR
reactions use PCR primers and master mix
both these are actually expensive
reagents
so if we can reduce the reaction volume
we can reduce cost but at the same time
also increase increased throughput
in order to achieve these smaller
reaction volume you have to use precise
liquid handles and liquid dispensers
the surface and mantis devices are great
low volume dispensers that yield good
precision and we use these for master
mix and magnetic V dispensers
the echo is really good at small volume
dispense
but also at individual well-to-well
transfers
it's any well to any well capability is
really unique to the instrument and we
use the echo to transfer 100 nanoliter
of primers
transferring 109 liter by hand is I
would say impossible
and then as the bulk liquid Handler we
use firm Matrix fast which is a
relatively new device
bulk is probably not the right term here
since we use only one microliter
transfers but the bulk refers to the
fast stamping at or 96 input plates to
384 PCR plates and also copying the
output from pcr1 into a pcr2 blades
we also use the fast for illusion so
again automation here allows to use
smaller valve format plates 384 plates
smaller reaction volumes and smaller
volume transfers
and this is a picture of our NGS process
that we have today we don't have fancy
robots yet but that's sort of the point
we use walkup instrumentation that
allows us to use process development but
while we use the Walker instrumentation
we use equipment tailored for low volume
handling so we already get those
benefits
next I'd like to talk about how
automation
can enable sophisticated doe experiments
design of experience doe allows to study
manufacturers and their interactions
simultaneously
and to give a little background on
design of experiments we can consider
this graphic here that I took from the
reference mentioned on the slide as well
let's say we have an experiment where we
want to optimize the response as a
function of temperature and
concentration what we could do is vary
the temperature first on the x-axis
we say let's say we have six
measurements indicated by the blue
crosses and one of them gives us the
best response and that's the response
indicated by The Thin Red Circle once we
have the optimal temperature we can then
decide to vary the concentration again
with six measurements and within those
six measurements we have an Optimum
indicated by the thicker red circle here
however this is a false Optimum
because we have ignored the dependency
between temperature and concentration
instead if we vary concentration
temperature simultaneously we are able
to identify the surface describing these
two parameters and also be able to
identify the optimal point on this
surface indicated by the red circle
let's look at electric operation and
what factors influence the transfection
process there's actually many factors
could be the guide to cash ratio the
cells to rmp ratio the type of
transfection buffer the electrical pulse
pattern
let's say we want to set up such an
experiment and because it's biology
let's say we want four replicates per
point
note that of course some doe designs
allow you to get away with less replicas
but just for the sake of arguments let's
just assumed we want four replicates
that we put in the PCR plates
if now we also want to study three
different ratios of guide to cast we
would utilize three columns of the
plates
if now we also wanted to evaluate three
different pulses we would be using nine
columns and let's say we wanted to study
two different buffers we would be using
18 columns
note that here we have a so-called full
factorial design there are others
perhaps more optimal designs
uh doe designs but that would be beyond
the scope of this presentation here
imagine though you had to execute
experiment by hand
this would be tedious and error-prone as
you need to be very careful what mixture
goes where
and even worse there is no randomization
this means that this experiment is
actually a potentially subject to
systematic row or column effects ideally
you want to randomize the distribution
of the parameters across the plate
luckily we can use Auto automation to
enable these sophisticated experiments
we can use dispensers like the
background Echo to dispense guide RNA
and cas9 protein
we can use this other dispensers like
the Mantis or surges to dispense
different amount of cells
and these dispensers can also be used to
dispense different buffers
and when using automation we can also
program the Alonso nuclear Factor
automatically
this still might be doubting daunting to
translate
these doe designs into robot
instructions but fortunately some
companies provide dedicated software
that help translate these doe designs
into robot instructions and one of these
companies is synthase they have for
example doe for assay developments you
can definitely if you want to know more
information
now lastly I'd like to highlight how
automation results in proper data and
metadata storage
one of the tasks at hand in cell
engineering is monitoring cell growth
percent confluency is the amount of well
area that is covered by cells
on the left image there should be one
cell somewhere it's hard to see but on
the right you can see clearly that we
have a large number of cells
once we have a large numbers number of
Wells with high confluency it is time to
expand from let's say a 384 route plate
to a 96 well plate we monitor the
percent conferency using an Imaging
cytometer
imagine having to do this by hand you
would load the plate in the in the
instrument that would give you a data
file but you would have no context
context is typically referred to as
metadata what cell line do we have how
many days after transfection are we
Imaging what are the Imaging settings
that were used
now when running automated experiments
metadata can be easily captured again
due to the need for having systematic
processes
we will know exactly how much time
has has expired since the last
transfection
so proper data storage has an added
benefit it also enables Data Mining and
machine learning models
and this is the work cell where we
monitor cell growth at syntago blades
run 24 7 in this automated work cell
it's also an ISO 5 environment and a
cycle between incubator at 37 degrees C
and imaging systems just to give you an
idea about the throughput since January
2021 we have processed uh over 6.6
million images
these images are automatically uploaded
to AWS Amazon
web storage and contextualized with info
from the barcode reader so as the
barcode reader that can probe
information
um
about what cell is in that plate
um here is a little video about uh this
work cell
we will see we see on the upper left a
plate being eject from the blade reader
that played is oriented from the
landscape into the portrait position and
then is being brought into the incubator
that you can see on the lower right in
the picture the incubator retracts the
plates
and it will provide a new plate after
some time
so I've tried to highlight five benefits
of automation
and there's one more point I'd like to
discuss
is how we can achieve scalable
automation Solutions using apis
API stands for application programming
interface that's a software intermediary
that allows two applications to talk to
each other
the clients for example a laptop can get
something put something post something
or delete something from a database
and this interconnectivity is crucial in
building out an automation facility
and this is a trend observed in the last
few years only that major vendors have
recognized the needs for apis in life
science
and many come up with apis into their
software
as an example let's consider gbg green
button go which is biocera scheduler
evidently the scheduler already has API
capabilities into into instrumentation
using.net client wrappers or using grpc
but the third bullet point in the slide
here says new for the rest web API
the blue box shows what we can do with
these remote API commands we can load a
process start and stop a process get
status of a process all remotely show
hide GUI get set variables execute
certain scripts query data tables handle
errors subscribe to events
these are very useful if you want to do
remote monitoring or remote control of
your processes
also Hamilton which is a liquid handling
vendor has recently
come up with a vector API that allows
to load methods start and terminate runs
from a remote client and this API is as
new as of 2020.
and so let's talk a little bit about why
apis get so much attention
the reason is that we don't want
monolithic protocols for example in our
Imaging scenario we don't want one
Imaging order where the scheduler would
have to sit idle for six hours instead
we want to keep it Nimble and we want
another program to launch just the
Imaging program the other program would
be responsible for the waiting time
so apis actually allow that process to
happen so we can have another
application in the middle of the figure
here with the business logic that can
um submit orders to the work cell or to
the liquid handlers
but these business logic programs can
also interact with laboratory Innovation
Management Systems
um the business logic can actually be
written in a relatively lightweight app
in in Python
um
furthermore if we expand on this model
we can also have data processing
programs that interact with the with the
entire application
now while this may look really complex
and and maybe
people in
lab automation aren't quite used to apis
there's many
um many external third parties that can
help there's zavo R3 and Mosaic that can
help with laboratory Inventory
management systems
Federal size can help with data
processing artificial is a company that
can help you write your business logic
around controlling your work cells or
liquid handlers but also very
importantly
this structure is actually a standard
software engineering structure so we can
Leverage The richness of software
engineering as that that that exists
outside of life science into life
science Cloud applications have been
have grown in in general software
engineering in let's say the 2010s and
I'm very excited that in the 2020s we
see that technology being brought over
into life science
so this brings me to the summary I hope
I could show you today that automation
helps you to bring standardization
avoids bottlenecks allows process
miniaturization enable sophisticated doe
experiments and results in proper data
and metadata storage even if you do not
um
achieve full automation these these
value items can be created along the way
like even the cartoon indicates the
points
when we want to build a sand castle even
if we start with a little amount with a
flag on it's already something and the
kids can be happy
I've also highlighted how scalable
automation Solutions can be built using
apis
thank you very much for your attention